Transcriber: Ecemnur Yavuz
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
George Orwell’in
1984 kitabındaki kameralar
bizim mahallede, pencerelerde
dedikodu yapan teyzelerin yanında
çömez kalıyorlar.
Bu teyzelerle ilk deneyimimi
bundan iki yıl önce yaşadım.
Şu anda devlet onaylı olup
o dönemde devlet onaylı olmayan sevgilimle
paylaştığım evden dışarıya çıkarken,
teyzelerden bir tanesine yakalandım.
Bu teyzeyi daha önce hiç görmemiştim.
Büyük ihtimalle yazı memleketinde geçirmiş
ve daha sonra apartmanına geri dönmüştü.
Yan apartmandan,
penceresinden durdurdu beni
ve şu soruyu sordu;
“Çocuk var mı?”
Böyle kalakaldım.
Böyle durdum.
Böyle bir birden böyle pısırdım.
“Hayır” dedim ve günüme devam ettim.
Sonra kendime çok kızdım.
Üstüne çok düşündüm.
Dedim ki;
Benim konuşmalarımda
böyle aksaklıklar hep oluyor.
Bir şeyler dayanamıyor konuşmaya çünkü.
Ben bunu böyle elimde tutsam problem mi?
Tamam…
Kendime çok kızdım.
Dedim ki;
“Neden cevap vermek zorunda
hissettim kendimi?”
Cevap vermeseydim ne olurdu?
Daha akıllıca bir cevap
verebilir miydim acaba?
Bu teyzeye bu anı bir öğreti anına
çevirebilir miydim acaba?
Hemen böyle eğitmen kimliği
devreye girdi birdenbire.
Ve şunu fark ettim;
Şu elle tutamadığımız,
gözle göremediğimiz,
kendimizi
hiç etkilenmediğimizi sandığımız
ve hep başkalarına attığımız
şu toplumsal baskı olayını
ben aslında kafama atılan
bir taş gibi hissetmişim o anda.
Ve kalakalmışım.
Böyle hayır deyip yoluma devam etmişim.
Son iki yıldır da bu konu üzerine
çok fazla düşünüyorum.
Nasıl cevap verebilirdim?
Ne yapabilirdim?
Bu uygun bir soru mu?
Sorulması aslında…
ve şu sonuca vardım;
Biri size çocuk var mı diye sorarsa,
ona hangi pozisyonda seviştiğini sorun.
Çünkü teknik açıdan baktığımızda
bu iki soru arasında aslında
hiçbir fark yok.
Teknik ve lojistik açıdan…
Sosyal açıdan fark olabilir.
Ahlaki açıdan belki fark olabilir.
Ama tekniğe indiğimiz zaman,
aynı şeyi soruyoruz.
Aslında savunduğum şey de şu;
Toplum tarafından daha kabul gören soru
yani çocuk var mı sorusu
hangi seks pozisyonunda sevişiyorsunuz
sorusuna göre daha fazla mahremiyeti
ihlal eden bir soru.
“Şimdi bir dakika,
bunu biraz açıklaman lazım bize”
diyebilirsiniz çok haklı olarak.
Evet "çocuk var mı?" sorusu
belki içimizi rahatlatıyor.
Oh, işte böyle aileye dair
bir şeyler sordum.
Karşımdaki insanı tanıdım.
Kendimi çok iyi hissettim.
Öte yandan, biri size
hangi seks pozisyonunda sevişiyorsunuz
diye sorduğu zaman biraz böyle
çarpıntı kalp sorunları yaşamanız
çok doğal aslında.
Bunun sebebini varsayımlar üzerinden
inceleyerek anlayabiliriz aslında.
Biri size "çocuk var mı?"
diye sorduğu zaman
sizin hakkınızda
birtakım varsayımlar dolanıyor kafasında.
Aynı şekilde biri size
hangi seks pozisyonunda sevişiyorsunuz?
diye sorduğunda da
sizinle ilgili bir takım varsayımlar
dolanıyor kafasında.
İlk soruyu ele alırsak…
Biri bana "çocuk var mı?"
diye sorduğu zaman
benim hakkımda neler varsayıyor?
Bir, bu soruya
cevap vereceğimi varsayıyor.
İkicisi, bu sorunun cevabının benim için
çok kolay olduğunu varsayıyor.
Yani ‘evet’ ya da ‘hayır’…
Üç, heteroseksüel olduğumu varsayıyor.
Çünkü yoksa büyük ihtimalle
hayatıma dair böyle bir detayı
çok fazla merak etmeyecekti.
Ya da zaten
çocuk sahibi olmayacağımı düşünecekti.
Dört, evli olduğumu varsayıyor.
Beş, üreyebildiğimi varsayıyor.
Yani üreme sistemimle alakalı
herhangi bir problem olmadığını
ve herhangi bir sıkıntı
yaşamadığımı varsayıyor.
Ve bunu benim üzerimden varsayıyor.
Çünkü genelde
kimse spermlerden şüphelenmiyor.
Hep problem yumurtalıkların
üstüne kalıyor.
Bunun dışında bu kadar özel bir detayı
hiç tanımadığım bir teyzeyle
paylaşacağımı varsayıyor.
İkinci soruya geçersek.
“Hangi seks pozisyonunda sevişiyorsun?”
Bu soru ötekinin yanında
çok masum kalıyor aslında.
Çünkü sadece karşınızdaki insanın
cinsel olarak aktif olduğunu
ve bir miktar seks pozisyon bilgisine
sahip olduğunu
varsayıyorsunuz aslında.
Bir de yine karşınızdaki insanın
bu kadar özelini
sizinle paylaşacağını varsayıyorsunuz.
Birinci soruda
sekiz on tane varsayım varken,
ikinci soruda kişinin mahremine,
özel hayatına dair
sadece üç tane varsayım var.
Dolayısıyla hangisi daha zararlı
hangisi daha zararsız
çok da fazla tartışmaya gerek yok aslında.
Peki, bu neden, neden böyle?
Kamusal alanda
biz cinselliği sansürlüyoruz,
özel alanda da
cinselliği bastırıyoruz.
Yani sansürbasyonla
bastırmasyonlar toplanıyor
ve karşımızdaki
mevcut durumla karşılaşıyoruz.
Türkiye’de dolayısıyla cinsellik
ya kamusaldır ya da tabusaldır.
Orta, çok fazla alanda
yer verilmez cinselliğe.
Hâl böyle olunca da
seksolog unvanına sahip biri
karşınıza çıktığı zaman
ya da ben seksoloğum dediğiniz zaman
‘seks’den sonrasına
çok fazla odaklanmıyor insanlar.
Ya da ben cinsel eğitmenim dediğiniz zaman
'eğitim’ kısmına çok fazla kafa yormuyor
ama cinsellik üstünde baya bir duruyor.
Hâl böyle olunca da
aslında cinsel eğitimin var olmasına
yardımcı olacak zihniyetin
tam tersinde işliyor bizim kafalarımız.
Biz ne zaman ki cinsel kısma değil de
eğitim kısmına takılacağız…
Biz ne zaman ki
seksolojiyi seksten ibaret değil,
insan cinsellik bilimiyle ilgilenen
bir bilim olarak algılayabileceğiz…
Ne zaman cinselliği
birinin birine yaptığı bir şey değil de,
insanların isterlerse tek başlarına,
bir partnerle veya birden çok partnerle
deneyimleyebilecekleri
bir şey olduğunu anlayacağız
ve bunu kabul edeceğiz…
Biz ne zaman cinselliği ve cinsel eğitimi
ergenlikte birdenbire hormonlarla başlayan
bir süreç değil de anne karnında başlayan
ve ölümümüzle sonlanan
bir süreç olarak algılayabileceğiz,
o zaman bireysel meraklarımızın,
‘çocuk var mı?’ sorularının
toplumsal haklardan üstün olmadığı
bir toplum yaratmaya başlayabileceğiz.
Teşekkür ederim…